Amazon studios invites you to enter the most brutal harsh
unforgiving world. Since Amazon's warehouses in the boys.
See what the DC universe would look like.
If Zach Snyder never had to take a studio note.
My grandchildren got incinerated Lamplighter at the birth of my life.
So thoroughly they weren't even tickling.
Where Superman is a stone cold psychopath wonder woman is a jaded alcoholic.
The flash is a junkie. Who's lost his edge. Aquaman is a sexual predator.
Martian Manhunter is a creepy perv.
Batman is pretty much the same and they all worked for a company with the
outward facing cheerful, Polish of Disney, but the internal money,
hungry killer instinct Tov also Disney.
Sequel. After sequel, after sequel.
Step into the adorkable shoes of Huey.
He's a pansy who comes from a long proud line of pansies.
You don't have the fight. You'd never have either do I.
Who's cultivated the power to back out of literally everything.
I don't want to go to a second location with you.
I don't think I can do this anymore. I need to go home. No, no, no, I can't.
I can't do this. No, no, no, no, no. I can't do this. I can't do this.
But Huey will go full Batman. When they kill off his Robin
and joined the boys of vigilante group dedicated to keeping superheroes in
line. And by in line, we mean dead
featuring this extremely French guy. And when we see.
You, don't stir you fold. That's what makes them Sparky.
This extremely into his girlfriend guy is if you want.
Watch that episode of Downton Abbey, then I'm going to be one behind them.
We're not going to be able to binge watch together. You know,
I'd much rather be at home, rubbing on them, toes, baby. I just you're right.
You're right.
This extremely MacGuffin girl and this cogni a-hole who everyone is extremely
unhappy to see compared to.
In your promotion, Susan, what are you doing here?
I thought we agreed that you were never going to come out here.
Easy bros at 40,000. Yummy. I mean,
why else would you show your face around here? Oh, hell nah. Do you want, yeah,
like the mold on my laundry room tiles, you scrape it up.
Comes right back.
No, come to think of it. No, one's happy to see each other on the show.
I guess friendship just isn't edging enough.
Until this frog. This was coming.
Speaking of edge,
prepare for a show that feels like it was written by these two sneaks up on the
deep.
And the boom down makes us shark bite transitions.
So that isn't content with just showing how superheroes would use their powers
for evil, but give them humanizing backstories and achieve ploy for sympathy.
Like how this disgraced white collar criminal has a kid.
Remember your old man or how the sexual deviant has a kid spends.
Most of his free time with his son. He's got a son.
Or how this mass murderer as a kid, your father,
or how this mass murdering corporate officer, you get the point.
I hear season two has a literal Nazi. Join the team, but don't worry.
I'm sure she wants to have kids someday, but in the darkness,
there is Starlight the newest hero in town with a power to cut down the VFX
budget by blinding the entire screen.
Watch her follow the girl in her first semester of college hero's journey.
Show us your and grow from unbelievably wide-eyed and naive to woke Epic
Gnostic Renegade. In the span of two months,
I'm done pretending only to find that our activism can be co-opted repackaged
and soul by the very forces she was fighting. Again.
Watch her stand up and fight back for all of us.
Citizens Starlight coming this ball.
This is why capitalism remains undefeated. Y'all so enjoy season one of a show.
That's able to address everything from corporate greed to the me too movement
with everything from laser babies,
how was diabolical to finger blasting a Gill hole God
in a series that reveals the unsettling truth of our superhero obsessed culture.
We're not suspending disbelief. When we watch our hero soar,
we're suspending disbelief that they wouldn't burn us all to the ground.
I know.
Save Martha story. New Zealand,
Jack Sparrow, Sylvie,
Louis C K let's go to the couch,
have a nice warm pizza row and wait for this all to blow over the it.
Cowed American psycho Twilight sparkle
adventures, and super babysitting OJ sprints in the AAT.
The 7 cents and mentees were seasoned to four.
A few more. I don't think it's Morgan Freeman up there or anything,
but by ourselves.
Wait he's mother's milk. That's gotta be mistake, right? Shouldn't she be?
Mother's milk there. Fixed it for you the year 2020.
He, he just, when he can't get any more horrible,
get a little more horrible.
An exposition news live whenever it's convenient.
Allowing superheroes international defense of more people where maybe I wouldn't
have to say that they're a train versus shockwave.
The race of the century Starlight shocking. The Christian community.
Social media is still buzzing about her controversial speech.
I believe that our encounter was consensual.
What I want to know who's that dude, this stuck is in her face. She should
all super cops are.
You need someone to tease as the big villain for the second season of your
prestige TV show, you call John Carlo Esposito.
Want to watch more stuff like the boys click box to see us break down the best
superhero comedies of all time.
So you can decide what to Miley chuckle next I'm [inaudible]
every breath I take,
every move I make every bone I break. Every step I take,
I'll be stalking you.